hello my name is reto meier and welcome
to this week in Android development on
Monday August 12 2013 whilst weeks all
designers in the Bay Area come together
to talk about designing for Android
surprisingly few cyberneticists who came
along expecting to design and Android
the size and shape of San Francisco Bay
the Google Play game services team were
at it once again with another episode of
game on where Todd and Bruno talked
cloud save and jf showed us how to
detect overdraw using the hierarchy
viewer our design advocates introduced
design bites with Nick demonstrating
responsive design and Roman donning a
darker yet still color-coordinated
ensemble to explain how you can flatten
existing icons using Photoshop Chet
taught us some cartoon animation
techniques while remaining oblivious to
the logo shirt coordination requirements
and dannan oz anchor and jf went
backstage once more to answer questions
on anchor series of dev bites on making
apps beautiful and this week jf will be
talking about optimizing layouts with
hierarchy viewer an opening the
Australian top order for the fifth ashes
test and tune in for a new face in dev
bites with a new clip on image
pixelization if you're in Europe now
will be a great time to plan a vacation
with Dan Galpin heading up the game's
invasion starting with a stop at the
Google's developer group meet up in
London on the 15th that's all for this
week and add our development be sure to
check out this week's dev and design
bites because it just won't do without
you